well Ryan Matt gentlemen congratulations
the two of you have made it past the
first forging round in our best and
domestic competition which means that
the two of you are going back to battle
it out from your home forges for four
days now Ryan because you impressed the
judges most in the first round with your
blade you get the choice of one of these
three blades to build against your
competitor here now we've got the Hook
sword
the killage
and finally the panabas
what are you thinking let's go with the
killage the killage all right
the killage traces its Origins back to
the 15th century Ottoman Empire
this lightweight sharp curved blade was
specifically designed to be wielded
single-handedly making it ideal for
warriors on Horseback to deliver deadly
slashes upon enemy attackers this
formidable weapon was previously
featured on season 5 of forged and fire
where both Smiths overcame complications
with the length of the blade and the
ornate longer but ultimately an extreme
Bend taken during the strength test cost
one Smith the competition
good luck we will see you in four days
good luck and good luck man
[Music]
I'm Ryan Searles I'm a 20 year old
artist in bladesmith from Thornton
Colorado I've always loved to craft and
build things with my hands and when I
found out I could play with fire and
Hammer steel I mean come on what's not
cooler than that I want to shoot for a
braided Mosaic Damascus
whoa I'm going to stack up fill it of
about 28 layers Forge it out chop it
into tiles and I'm able to create a
braided Mosaic I got this sword forged
out to where I want it to be and I'm
ready to go for the heat treat alrighty
if I don't get this played hard that
could be
out on this oh yeah we gotta work
there's a slight warp to the right so I
know I got to put it between two two by
fours and clamp it up otherwise if I
can't get that warp out now it's gonna
bite me in the butt later
that's pretty straight
I want to fit the long Jays and handle
together I has to be inlaid just so I
can get a very tight and nice fit up so
it's time to get the blade into the acid
and see this pattern pop all right
moment of truth
look at that
yeah we got a killage I brought my a
game can't wait to see what Matt does
and can't wait to hopefully get that 10K
there we go
[Music]
my name is Matt Roberts I'm 41 years old
and I've been making knives for about 20
years now I've been practicing law now
for about 14 years my goal is to win the
competition so I can have the bragging
rights and frankly being sufferable to
my friends
more so than I am already I'm forging a
coarse ladder pattern in this Blade the
hardest part of this build is going to
be forging the Damascus and making sure
I have a very solid Billet this far into
the process if the blade fails
making another blade in the time
remaining is frankly impossible
yeah
we're good
I want to have more mass in the handle I
also want to be able to have a bigger
more contoured handle than be more
comfortable to the user
a rough shape
there's some gapping between the handle
and the guard try to fill these the best
I can I don't think any of the flaws are
going to affect its functionality
they're just cosmetic and they're ugly
got the handle done and that doesn't
look half bad I think overall it came
out okay I'll be looking forward to
seeing the sword used I think that'll be
fun
foreign
test
Ryan Europe first you ready for this
let's let's do it
all right Ryan let's talk about your
Achilles sword here first up I
appreciate the beauty of the Damascus
pattern you have there also what I like
about this is that it's got that classic
killage look where you got parallel
lines and then slowly curve up that's
what we like with a historical piece
like this now you're handled
construction everything is smooth no
sharp corners on that your Edge is sharp
it almost cuts through all the way on
the big carcass and the the Tommy mats
overall your weapon you'll kill awesome
Matt your turn you ready I'm ready
[Applause]
[Music]
all right Matt let's talk about your
killage it's not quite the historic
accurate killage because you don't have
those parallel lights it immediately
goes down into a curve your handle
construction is also not the typical
killage look but your Edge is razor
sharp you've got a very nice balance to
wield this weapon and overall your
killage will kill thank you very much
bladesmets Welcome to our Dynamic
strength and cutting test
I'm going to attempt to cut through
these Vines and smash these skulls I'm
not going to go easy I'm gonna have fun
with these and Ryan you're up first you
ready to go let's break some skulls
foreign
your Edge is still very very sharp so no
glinting or anything cut beautifully and
overall tested very well good job
awesome thank you
all right Matt it's always more fun for
the second guy right I'm ready oh I'm
ready too let's go
foreign
nice job thank you I like the blade I
like the weight the Damascus came out
beautifully you have the slightest bits
of glinting I mean it's very minimal
your handle
A little unorthodox and right in this
area I wish I'd round it off a little
bit more right because it's a little bit
sharp right where my thumb sits on this
part but nothing's loose nice job thank
you very much
well gentlemen you gave us two swords
that performed outstanding in our tests
but at the end of the day only one of
you can leave here as a fortune five
Champion getting a check for ten
thousand dollars after discussion our
judges did make a final decision
today's sports fire Champion is
Ryan congratulations Matt you missed out
by just a little bit and Jay's going to
tell you why
Matt you brought us a great sword and a
great performer you should be very proud
of what you did but you did have a
little bit of glinting on the skulls
during the strength test and the handle
it's got some hot spots and I could feel
him when I'm swinging it big thing
though is historical accuracy what you
brought us is a little bit off from the
traditional killage and that's why we're
sending you home I understand well Matt
you brought us a beautiful blade that
did perform extremely well but
unfortunately your time this competition
has ended I'm gonna have to ask you to
please step off the fourth floor
congratulations man great job thanks man
the whole thing it was fun it was
exciting it was challenging it was
everything I was looking for
well Ryan congratulations that makes you
a fortune fire Champion you'll be
receiving a check for ten thousand
dollars man congratulations thank you
[Applause]
forged and fire Champion what oh man it
feels good I mean Matt was a insane
competitor this feels good to make it
through all the tests and uh the 10
grand hey that's just a plus to me